it's an upscale clothing outlets but in
1979 what happens in this spot signals a
new era in organized crime that will
last nearly 20 years it's Wednesday July
11 to 1979 a sudden burst of gunfire
shatters a sultry afternoon
[Music]
you had occurred at about 2:30 this
afternoon when two or more Latin males
entered the crown liquor store here on
the west end of the date land more they
were followed by two or three other
Latin males and then the shooting began
they came prepared to to do battle two
men lie dead on the liquor store floor
but what happens next is off the radar
of organized crime in Miami on the
hitmen exit the liquor store and turn
their guns on the public
to recall hearing the call being
dispatched as a machine gun in the
Dadeland shopping mall detective al
singleton is one of the first cups to
arrive on the scene the gunmen have fled
but they have left behind a scene of
carnage even the veterans were shocked
by what they saw that day
whoever's behind this it's not the
Mathew the Mafia are not active in Miami
but even if they were shooting civilians
is not their style we were used to
organized crime hits they weren't that
often in Miami but they did occur but in
those cases if there was an intended
target that person would be selectively
chosen and killed that would be it you
wouldn't just indiscriminately kill
witnesses that would just happen to be
the wrong place at the wrong time
and then the cops make another discovery
the killers used this customized armored
war wagon the getaway band was then
dumped in the malls north parking lot
inside were several rifles pistols and
shotguns some ammunition and flak vests
they used this 1978 Ford Econoline van
and that had been reinforced with
stainless steel to make it bulletproof
with two dead two wounded and a
swat-style mobile arsenal the media
begin to call it the Dadeland Mall
massacre Miami has never seen anything
like it but it's only the start of a
terrifying decade Dave land now set the
mark we had never encountered any County
violence like that in the face of the
killer's firepower the cops begin to
upgrade their own weaponry when you
recover 14 weapons used by contract
killers you realize that the standard
issue at least 38 was a poor
countermeasure to that kind of firepower
so